for example three what I wants to do is
draw our triangle just a little bit now
what we're gonna have is um you know
I've been trying to find X all this time
right so I'm gonna put X I'm gonna make
X and angle because that's what this is
about finding angles so if I've got this
angle over yeah suppose just as an
example and they'll give you a whole
bunch of different variations on this
right suppose I know this side over here
and I know this side over here okay now
we've looked at these kinds of things
before right what we need to do we
always need to start by identify which
sides have I got in relation to this
angle I can choose from adjacent
hypotenuse and opposite right so which
ones have I got this was the hypotenuse
good and this one's the opposite which
is why it's sign okay so I've got a
right equation here it's gonna be sine
of this angle X degrees is equal to
opposite on hype on our right so
opposite on hypotenuse right so that's
just gonna be uh huh yeah okay
now this point I am in exactly the same
position that I was here and I was here
right I've got the X here but there's
just this one thing I need to get rid of
there was a plus two had to get rid of
slightly minus two there was a times
three I had to get rid off so I divided
by three I have a sign now side is an
operation or a function just like plus
and multiplication but it's a bit
unoriginal the inverse right like
subtraction whatever the inverse of sine
is called sine inverse okay and you can
see it there I I alluded this a few days
ago why do you calculator above the side
button you hit shift and its side
shift and then soon okay
so if I do sign inverse to both sides
I've got sine inverse of side yes so I
did sine inverse of one side I'll do
society votes on the other side like
that okay I'll show you in a second okay
so what have I got here
all I did was just like both sides here
I took away two both sides here I
divided by three both sides here I've
done so nervous okay no he's not gonna
happen
just like P plus two minus two you just
get X right times 3 divided by three you
just get X right so what's gonna happen
on the left-hand side just get it you
just get X the sine inverse of the side
will cancel each other out
all right so you just get X 3 okay and
now I just need to put this into account
like I could just like I had to do 3
minus 2 and 2 24 divided by 3 you get a
good ii calculator let's say shift side
okay good
this will come up side inverse will come
up I bet you want to put our to that ah
right and what you get is so that was
how did I had I find this angle I used
it inverse right specifically I used
sine inverse as you can see this cos
inverse and is tan inverse as well okay
that's just worth mentioning there's not
super important right now but this thing
over here okay I just want you to put a
note on it which you may refer to later
if you come back to this you know next
year something like that
this part here I'd like you to write
this is a bit weird this is why I'm not
gonna dwell this too much but I want you
to have it written down there so that
later when you come back to this if you
ever like hey what's this about okay
remember how I said plus 2 minus 2
always disappears always cancels times 3
divided by 3 always cancerous sign in
this aside actually doesn't always
cancel so neatly only when you read my
neighbor triangle if you want to know
why exactly you can ask you about
afterwards but I just want you to have
that written down for now Kyle first yes
okay should we do an example I can do an
example before you do that either
temperature yeah okay in normal
triangles when it's not right angle
right and we will get to that eventually
you have to be a little more careful and
I'll show you why afterwards but that's
why I'm making a note of it now
all right just because Kyle asked for it
right let's do let's do another one
suppose we've got this I'm gonna go back
to calling this theta yeah okay sir
here's the diagram right again the first
thing you want to do is identify what
sides have I got relative to the angle
relative to theta okay and the answer is
well this side to the hypotenuse right
and the one centimeter that is measure
there on the side which one is it is the
opposite or a Dacian it's it's adjacent
it because it's right next to thea right
this one over here is opposite so the
one next to it okay so this is why we
started with that skillitz it important
for building one residence so be there
it's adjacent and hypotenuse I'm on top
cause that's the cosine okay so I'll
write down this equation I'll say cause
fear is gonna be adjacent on my potenuse
that's 1/2 okay so watching out that
square root sign it does come up quite a
bit so now if I say okay I want to get
rid of the cause just like I got rid of
the sign here right I'm going to do cos
inverse to both sides you can see just
like we did shift side before you can do
shift cause and that'll take you to
class zero okay so all right this
okay so then what happens where Viki are
the Thetas just left by itself right so
for the same reason over here you don't
do what's in right angle triangles
explain why later but then you pop it
right into your calculator right and you
have 45 yeah exactly the same thing but
if you get opposite adjacent then by the
way just as a point of interest the
reason why I chose these particular legs
is because if I have 45 degrees that's
what you're telling me
and it's exact it's not an approximation
what would this other angle be in the
qualifier it would also be 45 so what
you got here is not just a right angle
triangle it's an isosceles triangle
right it's so in fact uh these two
angles are equal so this sides now and
he will also be one set of it up you can
go ahead and check it out if you want
with Pythagoras it'll work you out